i couldn't ufc star that excites i mean
listen
i'm not keen on the little but conor
mcgregor you can't deny the action that
he brings you know what i mean he he
doesn't provide a lot of excitement he
does he does rightly or wrongly so
we'll go with that one i guess i
shouldn't have said that
i'm michael the count bisping and i'm
going to be answering questions from the
sport bible audience
what was the proudest moment of your
career proudest moment of my career i
often get asked this question and it's
not easy to answer because obviously one
would think you know becoming champion
of the world but then of course
to defend the belt and come back to
manchester and bring the belt home but
we'll go with manchester bringing the
ball back and defending it there how
does um becoming a ufc hall of famer
rank in there
yeah well when i was a kid rightly or
wrongly um all i cared about was
fighting which is a stupid thing to care
about really is and that's definitely
you know kind of a personality flaw if
you will but that's who i was and if
you'd have said to that young kid that
uh one day the greatest fighting
organization that ever existed on planet
earth is going to put you in the hall of
fame i don't think he would have
believed you so uh for me it's an
incredible honor how did it feel to win
the ufc middleweight championship yeah
it was great you know obviously uh being
a lifelong fighter to fight for the belt
was always a dream of mine and to
realize that goal and to actually win
was fantastic certainly against luke
rockhold who i didn't care for at the
time as well so that was even more
satisfying and then
of course to get a first round knockout
that was uh the icing on the cake and
then when you combine all that and then
the first and only british guy to do
that that was a very very proud moment
for me
and to represent my country the people
that have given me so much support over
the years truly did mean the world to me
how much time did you actually have to
prepare for your title shot yeah so i
was uh up in canada doing a bit of
filming and you know so i went out and i
went to a basketball game i had a few
beers and uh you know woke up the next
day feeling a bit rough and then went to
the gym to try and sweat out all the
booze because i was due on set that
night so i wanted to look half decent
and uh as i was walking in my phone
starts
growing up like a christmas tree and uh
yeah dana white had just been on espn
and announced that i was fighting luke
rockhold for the bell in two weeks time
probably problem was was that i was in
canada i was still shooting a movie i
had been near a gym an mma gym in about
three months you know so uh it wasn't
ideal circumstances
but it all worked out
which current ufc star excites you the
most a current ufc star that says i mean
listen
i'm not keen on the little
but conor mcgregor you can't deny the
action that he brings you know what i
mean he he does provide a lot of
excitement he does he does rightly or
wrongly so we'll go with that one i
guess i shouldn't have said that
what is your opinion on youtubers
fighting we're talking about youtubers
and boxing uh jake paul obviously who's
everyone's probably thinking of and i
actually respect the guy because there's
no prerequisite
to getting involved with combat sports
that you've got to come from a tough
childhood or anything like that that
doesn't have to be the case you just got
to have a passion for it and and and
apply yourself i'm just not a fan of the
people that it calls out you know what i
mean how about someone your own size
that actually boxes that isn't past a
cell by day you know what i mean would
you fight jake paul
i mean yeah i mean i guess
i guess you know i'm not sure he'd want
that to happen let's be honest but yeah
why not yeah give me a few quid smack up
a youtuber what was the toughest moment
of your career the toughest moment of my
career it was more phase if you will the
whole eye saga if you will um you know
obviously it's well documented i lost a
vision in my right eye and to be able to
compete was very very difficult so i
thought my career was taken away i was
you know uncertain where my life was
headed whether or not i was gonna have a
career
so what states you're in at the moment
what states my eye yeah i mean this is a
this is a prosthetic lens so it's it's
uh i know what you want you want you
want the old classic everyone wants it
[Laughter]
could you just it's the camera boom no
it is yeah i mean the best three grand
they ever spent because as you can see
without it it looks it looks a mess
build your ultimate ufc fighter from
current and former pros oh
oh uh all right so
in terms of striking we'll go with
anderson silva
in terms of fight iq you know strategy
game plans we'll go with georgetown
pierre
uh wrestling will go with daniel cormier
jiu jitsu will go with
damian meyer
and conditioning we'll go with britain's
old michael the campus baby
how's that how would you stack up
against that fighter do you think oh
i'll get my kid
if you weren't a professional mma
fighter what would you be uh what would
i do i mean i was trying to be a dj
you know i was a dj in iqv back in the
day i put a lot of time and effort into
that but uh i soon realized that i
wasn't gonna be the next carl cox and i
thought right i need to get a real job
uh i don't know yeah probably still
messing them out of the decks
which british fighter should fans be
most excited by
well you know to be honest right now
british mma has never been in a better
position tom aspinall 4-0 in the ufc all
stoppages definitely future contender in
the heavyweight division i mean he's
already a contender darren till everyone
knows who darren till is there's paddy
the body there's arnold allen arnold
allen's on like an eight fight winning
streak of course leon edwards he's
fighting kamara uzman for the belt he's
got a good chance of winning that so as
i say right now british mma we are
standing strong on the world scene
why haven't you fought ksi yet uh yeah
look that good question i have tried
so hard with this team to make that
happen i'm ready
i'll fight him anywhere anytime anyplace
i've said we can do it in london